Віталій Хронюк пішов захищати Україну добровольцем у лютому торік.
За майже рік повномасштабної війни він зрозумів, що мріє про велику родину.
У мене такі були відчуття, коли там артобстріл і ти просто лежиш, молишся Богу, і ти молишся, щоб вижити.
Але і в цей момент думаєш: "Так хочеться, щоб хоч дитина була, залишилася, і кохана…
Після себе залишити щось…
Віталій вирішив скористатися послугою кріоконсервації - заморозки чоловічої сперми.
Завдяки цьому його дружина Анна зможе скористатися біоматеріалом свого партнера, поки він буде на фронті,
або ж якщо із ним щось станеться.
Дівчині було складно звикнути до думки про те, що чоловік може не повернутися,
але врешті вона погодилася з його рішенням.
Якщо жінка чи дівчина втратить свого коханого чоловіка,
то в неї буде потім можливість, коли вона оговтається, хоча я розумію, що дуже тяжко буде оговтатися,
але в неї буде сенс для того, щоб продовжувати боротися,
продовжувати жити, і все таки вона буде носити в собі частину свого коханого.
Ембріологиня Оксана Лизогуб досліджує зразок людської сперми.
Цей біоматеріал готують до заморозки або ж кріозбереження.
Але насамперед треба оцінити якість: що активніше рухаються сперматозоїди, то краще.
Заморожена сперма зберігається у таких дюарах з рідким азотом
при температурі мінус 196 градусів за Цельсієм.
Ми морозимо суспензію сперматозоїдів у таких пробірочках.
Вона може зберігатися необмежено довго. Головне підливати азот і стежити за кріобанком.
Поки є азот, поки буде зберігатися. На властивості ніяк не впливає тривале зберігання.
У цій клініці зберігаються кілька тисяч зразків замороженої сперми,
жіночі ооцити і навіть ембріони.
Здебільшого свій біоматеріал віддають на кріозбереження люди, які планують ставати батьками згодом,
але хочуть зберегти "молоді" статеві клітини.
А також пацієнти з тяжкими хворобами, лікування яких призводить до безпліддя.
Протягом останнього року до клініки також почали звертатися військові.
Тут теж чоловіки в такій ситуації складній, яка може вплинути на їхню фертильність.
Якщо вона вплине погано, вони використають цю сперму.
Якщо чоловік помре, дружина зможе використати сперму його,
ми сподіваємося, що так буде. І народити спільну дитину з чоловіком, якого вона кохала.
У нас дуже крута армія, туди йдуть дуже розумні люди… з дуже класними генами, якщо можна так сказати.
Мені здається, що вони мають продовжуватися. Вони мають продовжуватися у своїх дітях,
це дуже важливо для України - залишити цих людей для розвитку нашої держави.
Військова Ярина Чорногуз нині на передовій, на напрямку Сватове-Кремінна.
Дівчина замислюється над тим, аби разом з чоловіком віддати свій біоматеріал на заморозку.
У мене така ситуація, що ми в одній роті з моїм чоловіком воюємо.
Це має як свої переваги, так і свої певні недоліки.
Звісно, це переживання одне за одного, у нас уже була не одна нагода, коли ми в такій ситуації,
що розуміємо, що це можуть бути останні хвилини.
Але нам поки що щастить. І ми з ним про це говорили і ось міркуємо навіть,
що наступного разу коли нас відпустять на кілька днів, то, можливо, ми навіть це зробимо.
Ярина визнає: серед військових тема заморозки сперми і яйцеклітин не надто популярна.
Утім після півтора року служби на передовій, військова зрозуміла,
що для неї важливо думати про майбутнє.
Ми зараз втрачаємо на війні наших найкращих людей - і чоловіків, і жінок.
Мені доводилося втрачати близьку людину, з якою були серйозні стосунки.
Так само я бачила… У нас ховали у підрозділі хлопців загиблих, у яких лишилися молоді дружини, дівчата.
І майже від усіх я чула ту саму річ: "Якби я знала, я б народила, чому так, я так хотіла,
я пропонувала, давай, а він казав ні, після війни, після перемоги"...
Ти стикаєшся з тим, що все, сліду про людину крім як у твоїй пам'яті більше не буде.
Репродуктологиня Ксенія Хажиленко відкрила свою клініку в грудні 2022 року.
Відтоді до неї вже звернулися десятеро військових.
Один із чоловіків разом з дружиною замовили кріоконсервацію ембріона, інші заморозили сперму.
У багатьох війна може забрати можливість мати дітей.
Низькі температури, обмороження - це все об'єктивні речі.
Але найчастіше функція страждає саме через поранення.
Це не секрет для армій тих країн, які давно воюють.
Причина - це не несприятливі умови, чоловіча фертильність влаштована таким чином,
що все ж таки після потрапляння в сприятливі умови усе ж таки частіше відбувається відновлення.
У жінок це складніше. Але там, де йдеться про поранення, там на жаль, невідворотнє, покращення не буде.
Для чоловіків заморозка сперми - нескладна процедура.
Потрібно лише здати аналізи на інфекційні хвороби і, власне, сам біоматеріал.
У столичних клініках усе це коштує від трьох до восьми тисяч гривень.
Але для військових у низці медзакладів Києва - і заморозка,
і зберігання протягом першого року безкоштовні.
Для жінок-військових пільг поки не пропонують, адже забір яйцеклітин набагато складніший.
Його вартість - до 70 тисяч гривень.
Заморожування клітин трохи інше по сутності, бо воно вимагає інтенсивного підготування для жінки.
Вона готується медикаментами спеціальними. І цей процес не страшний,
але він ресурсний в плані часу, медикаментозного навантаження, фінансово,
тому що медикаменти, якими проводиться підготування, недешеві.
Ще один нюанс, що стосується і чоловіків, і жінок - юридичний.
Адвокат Сергій Антонов пояснює: і в Україні, і в більшості держав світу
кріоконсервація ніяк не регулюється законодавством.
На практиці повернутися по свої статеві клітини й використати їх потім - зазвичай не проблема.
А ось якщо власник біоматеріалу помирає, тобто потрібна посмертна репродукція,
- юридично ситуація складніша.
У нас у законодавстві є також така прогалина, що у нас незрозуміло, хто саме з родичів першого ступеня
родинних зв'язків чи другого ступеня може вирішити питання, якщо у них, наприклад, конфлікт інтересів.
Якщо наприклад,  батьки хочуть, а дружина не хоче.
Вона може подати позов і в тому ж судовому процесі заявити, що вона заперечує.
Потрібно з юристами обговорити, як краще діяти.
Тобто якщо це програма відкладеного батьківства, коли за життя це робиться,
то можна прописати відповідні документи, зокрема заяви про те,
що конкретно визначається, кому можна буде використати, як використовувати,
укласти договір з медичним закладом, у якому прописати, що у випадку смерті
медичний заклад зобов'язується передати [біоматеріал].
Психологиня Антоніна Картушинська консультує пари, які вдаються до кріоконсервації.
Вона радить підходити до планування народження дітей відповідально
- надто якщо в одного з батьків є ризик загинути.
Тут більше дорослий егоїзм. Про те, що я тебе кохаю, якщо я тебе втрачаю, то я хочу мати частку тебе.
А дійсно, дитина буде виховуватися не в повній сім'ї, де відсутній, наприклад, батько.
Але ж це не значить, що дитину не будуть любити, що вона не отримає належного виховання.
Перше - це індивідуальна потреба, тобто потреба індивіда,
коли я хочу - я хочу, я готовий. І друга потреба - це видова.
Тобто "мені потрібно". Це продовження виду, тобто я хочу продовжитися в цій дитині - це трошки інакше.
І тому зараз коли війна, коли активні бойові дії, потреба в дітях актуалізується
саме з цієї видової потреби - продовжити вид і залишити по собі слід, відродитися в дитині.
Фахівці з репродуктології застерігають, що війна лише загострить демографічну кризу в Україні.
І радять замислитися про майбутнє вже нині. На передовій це розуміють, як ніде.
Люди сподіваються на краще, сподіваються, що з ними нічого не станеться, що їм пощастить.
Віра, надія завжди живуть. Коли ти це робиш, ти ніби маєш визнати думку, що з тобою може щось статися.
Ти можеш або загинути, або отримати каліцтво. Для цього треба… планувати.
Планувати свою загибель. Не всі це можуть робити.